hey guys I'm Lucy and welcome to reality
check now the term procedural generation
is being thrown around a lot lately and
for good reason it's basically game
development magic well it's actually
very clever maps and programming but
let's face it that's its own kind of
magic usually with games the levels we
play our hand-crafted so everything from
the maps layout enemy spawn point and
decoration are deliberately placed in
specific areas in the environment and
they stay there take this Citadel in
Mass Effect no matter how many times I
visited or how many times I replay the
game The Citadel will always look the
same but when games have an element of
procedural generation it means that the
multitude of things like terrain
buildings and art textures are created
according to the parameters set by an
algorithm so they'll be different every
time you play now back in the day memory
limitations on gaming systems meant that
quite a few titles had procedurally
generated levels like for example XCOM
UFO defense from the early 90s XCOM got
rebooted with enemy Unknown back in 2012
and it shipped with about 18 maps that
is a lot but it's a finite amount that
the fans soon exhausted well X come to
the team at Firaxis have implemented a
procedural generation system that can
basically create an infinite number of
maps so theoretically you can play x
come to forever without ever seeing the
same level twice but how does it all
work I hopped on skype to the guy that
for access to find out so we learned a
ton of lessons from enemy Unknown with
what makes a fun map with respect to
cover distribution and and and again the
sort of subconscious elements of oh we
need this much color cover for this much
deco in this building to sort of sell
the building all of that is inherited
knowledge that we're bringing tax come
to but the team did have to build a
pipeline from the ground up for multiple
reasons because of the procedural map
set that we're talking about there now
not building a holistic giant map that
might be a bar with all of the external
elements completely hand placed and
static and never moving now they're sort
of thinking about everything in these
smaller sub maps so rather than bill
85 maturin man donde they're literally
working in hundreds and hundreds of maps
but smaller maps that all have to work
together in these countless ways 4s come
to so we have these things called
parcels and if you don't parcels those
are sort of like levels in an ex-con wat
they could be a building they could be a
park that could be anything you want it
to be and and they work on this thing
that we call plot system that is sort of
the transition matrix that kind of the
parcels pop into little empty holes so
the roads are essentially empty and
whether it's cars that drop down trees
telephone booths or whatever all those
kind of objects now they come in and
procedural chunks as well but what
happens to the parcels when you've got
more than one setting or plot type I
mean it would be really weird if there
was a convenience store in the middle of
a forest for example we should partial
parcels automatically by day they throw
them biomes so if it's if we're going to
a city center map it will call only city
center parcels for going to a wilderness
map but a call you know just wilderness
normalize pieces so that's the way we
kind of keep it kind of kind of grouped
so with the algorithm in place the game
knows how and where to place parcels so
that the level makes logical sense to
the player but why is that important
well for X's had to find out the hard
way while tinkering with procedural
generation in enemy Unknown and in the
end that feature didn't make it into the
final version of the game randomness can
be good if it fits the division of the
game and and it doesn't have to marry
with with ascetic with aesthetic and
logic if it's more of an abstract game
but in our world you know there is this
this narrative core in this platform
that you're on earth there has to have
you have to have an emotional connection
with earth you have to recognize the
convenience store that you see on the
corner things were just two random with
our original system where that that
emotional connection was completely
getting broken because there wasn't
enough logic behind it so you didn't
feel like you were saving earth you sort
of thought you were saving this
hodgepodge of earth-like components
arranged in a random way so we
we had to unify the two of mechanics and
aesthetics and narrative and that's what
we feel like we're done with XCOM 2 so
with so many different variables like
time of day setting enemy spawns and
general stuff in the environment how do
you make sure that it all works oh my
gosh yeah I remember our one of our
development directors said to me when I
talked to him about what the design is
going to be a Mexico to and while you're
working out he was like how are we going
to QA all of this it adds some
complexity to it but in some ways I
think it makes it a little easier
because you know it can you know what
part you're looking at that is swapping
or having the problem so once you adjust
it in one place it usually systemically
will fix it in others so it does make it
a little bit easier in some cases since
it is a bit more systemic and a little
less up um and hand done like it wasn't
in an ex-con one enemy unknown didn't
really ship with mod support but that's
not the case for XCOM 2 so you can
fiddler on to make your own procedural
levels if you want to you can take our
existing again hundreds and hundreds of
maps we've created that our parcels and
you can either modify those change them
just the materials just change the
textures or if you know how to model you
can create a whole new title set if you
want yourself if you have the skills to
do that it should be great I mean it's
it's super flexible if a modern wanted
they can make seventy percent of the
loan be fixed and thirty percent of it
be procedural or vice versa it's a
really robust system and I think going
to be great for modders so while there's
all these different components that sort
of lead to this this feeling of I may
have seen this before but not quite in
this way and then when you layer on top
you don't know what's going to be inside
and where the enemies lie and is there
going to be an objective inside this
time because we have procedural
objectives so you really get this
feeling of I I can play for it I can
play forever and not see the same exact
thing twice and we're very very very
excited
that so are you gonna be playing XCOM 2
until the end of time let me know in the
comments or on Twitter at Lucy James
games thanks for watching guys and I'll
see you next time for some more reality
check